did Zack Snyder just accidentally on
purpose reveal the new flash costume i'm
dave and this is your gamespot news
update filming for the Justice League is
gearing up for its april production day
and that means zack snyder will be
showing off a lot of pictures from the
set in the upcoming months recently the
director of the 2017 film took a picture
of himself and jason momoa who is
playing Aquaman what's really
interesting about the picture is far
from the background right behind the
mowers Aquaman costume is another
costume turns out that looks a whole lot
like the costume for the flash who will
make an appearance on March 25th in
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
zooming in a bit flashes golden wings on
the side of his head can be made out
it's a bit hard to make out but it looks
like a bit of a departure from the
costume seen on the TV series the flash
this outfit is shiny and has a bit more
of an armor looks wit matching the
heroes around him Ezra Miller will be
taking on the role of Barry Allen or the
flash in the film it's rumored that both
Miller and the mobile appear in Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice and many fans
are claiming they're spotting Flash's
speed force lightning in the trailer
have you been waiting to hear about the
flash before fully investing in Batman V
Superman let me know in the comments
section below or find me on twitter i'm
at arregle Dave thanks for watching and
fall your gaming and entertainment news
keep it gamespot.com
Oh